director David Gordon greens Halloween
the reboot sequel that directly connects
to John Carpenter's original film and
retcons the many less awesome follow-ups
that came after it featured an ending
that finally gave Laurie Strode played
by Jamie Lee Curtis the closure she'd
sought for 40 years while keeping
Michael Myers estate relatively open for
interpretation
but Halloween almost concluded on a much
different note obviously if you've come
this far in the video you should know
spoilers for the 2018 Halloween ahead by
the end of the film Lauri her daughter
Karen and her granddaughter Allison
trapped Michael inside Laurie's basement
then set the entire house ablaze it had
been safe to assume Michael would be
burnt to a crisp until the film cut back
to the flame filled basement that now
appeared to be Michael free fans who
stayed through the credits heard his
breathing just before the lights went up
which further signaled that he may have
made it out of the fire alive but an
early version of the film saw things
play out differently in a May 2017
script draft posted to Twitter Laurie
Allison and Karen originally named
Shanna come together outside Laurie's
house where Laurie engages in a
one-on-one battle with Michael rather
than a game of cat-and-mouse that ends
up with Michael locked in the basement
the alternate ending sees Laurie and
Michael getting into a knife fight
outside Laurie's luck against Michael
runs out when he drives a knife into her
chest she swings her own knife and
slices his arm here's where Karen slash
Anna enters the scene slowly opening the
front door armed with the high-tech
crossbow after Michael twist the knife
further forces Laurie to the ground and
then pulls the blade out Laurie's
daughter shoots Michael in the chest at
least that's what we can assume happened
there's a page missing from the
Halloween script that was shared on
social media next we see Laurie's
daughter and granddaughter flagging down
a pickup truck loading Laurie in it and
pulling away with the unnamed driver
seemingly in search of a hospital
somewhat similarly to the way the final
cut of the film ends the script then
cuts to a dark forest where Michael
staggers through the trees as he Yanks
and arrow out of his chest he ends up
standing among the shattered artificial
faces of mannequins likely a reference
to the area of Laurie's property where
she and her daughter held target
practice which we saw in the film he
then walks to a tree and sits down
touches the wounds in his chest
and looks at his missing fingers all
while breathing laborious ly as the
script notes he's exhausted and possibly
taking his final breath compared to how
Halloween actually ended Laurie Karen
and Alison having survived in
Michael's ultimate fate left ambiguous
this original conclusion would have
featured Laurie and Michael both on the
brink of death pretty thrilling and more
than enough room for a sequel right so
why didn't they go with this version two
words test audiences the filmmakers held
three shoots after test audiences made
it known that they didn't like the
ending very much and as cool as a knife
fight and crossbow scene would have been
it's hard not to agree sure the original
ending sounds pretty solid in most
regards but it was probably a good thing
that it was changed for the final cut
imagine it Laurie anxiously awaiting
Michaels returned for 40 years training
and raising her daughter to fight and
kill him to the point where the
authorities had to take her away only to
be stabbed and left bleeding in the back
of a pickup truck that would have been a
massive bummer with critics and fans
having highly praised Halloween and the
flick raking in hundreds of millions of
dollars at the global box office it's
all but inevitable that we haven't seen
the last of Michael Laurie Karen and
Alyson mabie Laurie will still get to
have that knife fight and Karen will
hoist the crossbow for another moment of
utter badassery in the possible sequel a
horror fan can only hope
[Music]